- So, your husband though,
he just - Chris Pratt -
he had a birthday,
right, a recent birthday?
- Oh yeah, last - last June.
- [Kelly] What'd you get him?
- I got him piggies.
- [Kelly] You got him actual pigs.
- Yeah, I did.
- What, like miniature ones?
- No.
- Well, actually what happened to me
when I was in high school
was I rescued this supposed miniature pig
- [Kelly] Oh.
- When I lived at my
parents' house (laughs).
And it turned into a giant pot-bellied pig
and rooted up my mom's entire lawn
- (laughs) I'm just laughing because of-
nobody's actually had a huge
pot-bellied - they're enormous.
- They're so big, very, very large.
Yeah, that's Bacon, my pig.
She's since passed away.
- (laughs) You named her Bacon.
- I know.
My little brother Christopher
actually named her Bacon,
so it's his fault.
But yeah, he has...
We have an amazing place
in Washington State,
so there's a lot of land there,
so the pig - these pigs
are not living with us.
- They're living in a very beautiful farm,
- [Kelly] On a farm, yeah!
- Loving life, very large now,
so I'm very excited that they
did not come to our house
because I was told they would stay small.
They did not.
- Yeah, I was told my dog
was gonna be miniature
and lies and deception!
- (laughs)
- Heifer's like forty-five pounds.
I'm like, "What?
"He is not fifteen to eighteen pounds."
- I know.
- That's awesomeness, y'all
have a farm in Washington?
Washington's beautiful.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's beautiful.
- Nice place to escape, that's cool.
- Yeah. Yeah, I grew up around animals,
so it's really fun and--
- [Kelly] I did as well. Yeah.
- I love it, it makes me so happy.
- Animals are so cool.
They're just loyal and nice,
and they're never mean.
- (laughs) So have y'all
ever had any unusual pets?
- I used to have this babysitter,
and she had a rooster.
- Oh, they can be mean.
- [Katherine] Yeah, and loud.
- That's the thing.
It was very mean.
Because she would go outside
and she loved the rooster,
because how could you
not love animals?
- And she would go outside--
- [Kelly] I don't
love roosters.
- and try to bond with it,
and it would try to bite her.
And at a certain point it was chasing her
all around the yard and
she climbed up a tree
and it bit her butt. And it was horrible.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God, that happened to me one time
in a little petting zoo.
My sister, I was holding her child
and this goat kept nippin' at my behind.
I was like, "Get your child off of me!"
'Cause I was holding
her kid, from the goat
and my sister's just laughing.
I'm like, "It's eating my butt!"
I was like, "Quit!"
Anyway.